he's Mike Love the co-founder the Beach
Boys they just released he did his first
solo album in 30 years and a special
double CD featuring new material as well
as re-recorded beach boy classics his
first single is called unleash the love
and great to have Mike Love and studio
here how are you thank you mr. Patrick
it's it's a delight to be here and I
want unleash the love to be Kevin love's
theme song does he know that
no we haven't spoken of it but he did
text me and and and I told him
originally I thought we were gonna be on
the show Monday and and I said oh well
beyond the Dan Patrick show Monday why
don't you call in or why don't we do
something and then then he texts me back
well we have a shoot around I said then
I texted him and said it was gonna be
Tuesday so so he he might call in I
don't know oh but I like that your your
programming this show that's exactly
what I'm doing but did you know that
Kevin was gonna when did you know Kevin
was gonna be a great basketball player
well my brother Stan who was as you know
in the NBA that people asked him is
Kevin better than you I mean when he was
you know in high school he says since he
was about 12 and Stan broke records at
the University of Oregon as a a duck and
he was a first-round draft pick he was
I'll be then Baltimore bullets yeah and
he would go to practice in his
flip-flops he was from the west coast
what are we gonna do you know in the
winter he'd be in Boots flip-flops were
you an athlete well not like these not
like my dad who was my dad my mom were
both athletic Mike my dad was all City
in at Washington High School when he was
like 17 years old and on the boxing team
UCLA and then my mom played golf she
could walk up the stairs on her hands
you know she was very athletic but her
real passion was music and that's what
informed us all and got us together for
Christmas parties and speaking of
Christmas a happy holidays everybody and
Kevin I remember my wife Jacqueline
talking reading out the night before
Christmas to Kevin and all those kids
when he was just a little guy
and then he grew up to be 6/8 well yeah
at least yeah
his dad site or up there close to good
well yeah yeah so it's you know sports
in music have been a family tradition so
it's kind of cool I was a long-distance
runner and you know basically I had to
go to high school summer school to stay
eligible because I you know lagged on
some there's there's a picture of Kevin
yeah Caleb what was the first band or
artist that caught your ear and you that
you decided you wanted to be in a band
well you know we were the like the first
rock group
keine don't you think and then the
Beatles and the stones and but you know
before that was rock and roll people
like all those individuals yeah
individual the Everly Brothers we love
their blend well I don't think there's
been a better harmony I know they never
leave a inspired us but we also were
inspired by the four freshmen who did
this really complicated four-part
harmony and we put that style of harmony
on top of the either the rock beat or
the ballads or whatever it was we were
crazy about harmony and that goes back
to childhood that goes back to Christmas
parties and stuff did you meet Elvis
yeah we met Elvis a couple times one
times he was one terror in the same
studio complex he was recording in one
big studio and we were on in studio
three where we did all our hit records
and then early to mid 60s and he wasn't
couldn't have been a nicer person is the
greatest guy competition with the
Beatles
well more like a rivalry and a sense in
a positive way you know it's a mutual
admiration thing I think you know we we
love their music and they loved ours and
we were competitive our song good
vibrations went to number one in 1966
and we were voted in the fall and I
think November of 66 we were voted
didn't number one group in Great Britain
number two big potatoes so I mean
nobody's been more successful in music
than the Beatles and you know Paul
McCartney and all the guys I was invited
by Mari XI to go to India which I'd
never been so I went and when I got
there all the Beatles were there it was
the most fascinating time of my life up
to that point because they started with
trance
did they did and I think Harrison George
Harrison was the guy who kind of
enlightened them on that
yeah well very much so he was into all
things in he studied sitar yes
he loved his meditation he wrote that
song my sweet lord Hari Krishna Hari
Rama and so I did a tribute to George on
the album and I have out called unleash
the love and I did a a tribute to George
he was a wonderful person a great great
guy very spiritual very you know very
low-key they call him the quiet Beatle
but what it was is he he was real
down-to-earth kind of thing he never
forgot his roots you know but if you
look at that window though Mike of the
Beatles with nine years of all of those
hit like anybody trying to keep up with
them it's pretty difficult
and then the stones were in there as
well the who came along I don't know if
there was anybody else who just get here
I mean that was a great time for music
oh it was a fantastic time for music and
don't forget Motown yes oh my goodness
The Temptations blew my mind they were
they were outstanding you came up with
who came up with a name Beach Boys a
record promotion guy in the West Coast
we didn't know what to call ourselves we
were these Pendleton's shirts you know
the plaid shirts over the t-shirt to
keep you warm as the Sun going down
you're at the beach but the we were
calling ourselves the Pendleton's and
they said no the song's called surfin
that was her first song that fall of 61
servant one at the Beach Boys it was
Russ Reagan who became a record company
president after you know years later but
he was a promo man I said well that's
better than what we've got so it's stuck
the Beach Boys but it fits did you feel
like you were married to then music that
would be sort of under that umbrella of
being a beach boy no I married a couple
different girls in the 60s
[Laughter]
did you have a crazy 60s oh well now
we're not gonna kiss until dim okay you
like to name names name names
how about numbers no the point is yeah
there are statistics to be talked about
but not on not on okay all right well
this is it's sports it's competitive
come on you survived it feels I did man
survived it
well yeah I don't know how much of the
band survived the sixties but what I did
is I was blessed and we all learn
meditation Transcendental Meditation in
1967 and in December in Paris at the
hotel Creole and we were there to do a
UNICEF show the benefit of children the
United Nations Marlon Brando and his
Tahitian bride were on the show Richard
Burton and Elizabeth Taylor were on the
show Victor Borge of the Danish you know
pianist and how great did Elizabeth
Taylor look back that she looked good
after party we were invited to an
after-party by Marlon brown oh you want
to get some breakfast it's like 1:00 in
the morning what's open and and we
didn't know much about Paris but he took
us to the Mac seems to praise Him in a
private party you know and he he was
awesome guy and and and it just there's
so many great stories there in my book
Good Vibrations my life is a beach boy
Congrats by the way the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame what was it 19 88 88 yes
remember about that night I remember
inviting Muhammad Ali to come sit with
us and go it was we spent two or three
days with with Muhammad Ali going out
dinners and well how'd that happen well
we were contemporaries of Muhammad Ali
we loved him because you know he
represented a lot of things like peace
that at a time when you know there was a
big movement towards war you know and he
I used to buy Muhammad speaks the
magazine when I was in high school I
thought it was fascinating you know so I
I have always had a admiration for in
fascination with different cultures
different ethnic groups lang
architecture you name it and and I guess
that's why I wrote this song unleash the
love the thing about mother nature she's
got a place for every creature the
beauty of God's creation is a diversity
for all of us it's a lesson that our
planets prized possession is our
differences yeah I think it's time we
all agree we got to unleash the love
yeah you ever forgot lyrics yeah
sometimes I'll drop a stitch at one time
we were in the the stadium where the
Angels play in Southern California and
the the place is packed it's sold out
the Beach Boys Chicago and the the upper
level that juts out was bouncing up and
down about a foot and a half or so I'm
thinking oh my gosh
and I was right in the middle of I get
around and I went and I you know I blew
my mind that this it'll look like a big
earthquake but they were people were
jumping up and down in the beat of the
music
best concert you were ever involved in
or saw there's a lot of great concerts
but probably the most incredible was we
did two concerts in one day on July 4th
back in the eighties the Philadelphia
Inquirer said there was Inquirer said
there was nine hundred thousand people
in the streets of Philadelphia and then
that eat that was the afternoon/evening
there was like three quarters of a
million in DC in front of the monument
you know that and so to see you guys
yeah yeah well and we had other people
okay yeah we had country R&B rock and
roll you know so but I thought back in
the 70s I said what could be better than
because US has been so good to us why
not do a free concert on July 4th no
yeah and so it was my idea we went and
did it and we did it a few times but
that one time that's a Guinness Book of
record kind of deal and a lot of
publicity here with Charles Manson dying
and the relationship with the beat Beach
Boys I didn't know it was that it wasn't
the Beach Boys it was my cousin Dennis
that's that's a distinction okay tell me
the story just so I have it correct
is there like his how he got involved
with your with Dennis Dennis picked up a
couple of hitchhikers these young ladies
and took him back to his home that
was renting in out and Sunset Boulevard
Will Rogers Park area at any rate so
then we went on tour and when he got
back these girls what happened to be
part of Charlie Manson's family and you
know so there was the diabolical and
divine we were we were all meditating
and stuff and then there was here comes
Charlie Manson
so Dennis actually wanted us to join the
group you know join the family but the
Manson Family yeah we declined
oh boy yeah I only met the guy once but
he was a music or thought he was a
musician or a writer yeah Dennis got got
him over to Brian Wilson's house my
cousin Brian's house where we had a
studio put in and yeah they recorded
over there but I took the tapes and gave
him gave him to our manager at the time
and said you know put him away well you
know it was because we didn't know that
he was crazy the way well we knew he's
crazy but we didn't know his murderous
yeah you know so it was a it was an
unfortunate part of our experience but
we weren't directly involved the most is
it was my cousin Dennis's you don't have
those tapes no I don't even know where
they are what's the one song though that
you'll never get you never get tired of
singing there's about ten okay
good vibrations California girls I get
around fun fun fun
you know I mean wouldn't it be nice
because they're all positive happy
upbeat so they are like you can't go
into a go oh I got it sing this and I
get around yeah well no no no I haven't
never had that that attitude
I am grateful and blessed that we can go
around the world I mean in Germany they
like our music in Japan they like our
music I mean we've been from Finland to
you know South Africa it's it's it's a
global thing it's but why does it work
did you ever wonder I think it's love I
honest to God before we were the Beach
Boys we got together his family and the
whole thing was because my mom set it up
I mean we had a grand piano
getting harp in her living room and we
got together not because we were gonna
make any money at it because we loved
music my my mom's my mom came from
Kansas is a five year old girl on a
train and they had no money they camped
on the beach in Southern California and
so my grandfather my father's side came
from Louisiana and in 1909 I started
working in the sheet metal industry
which I I've worked in briefly but so
there was no money involved but there
was the love of getting together and
harmonizing and so harmonizing is losing
your individuality in favor of the group
sound like the Everly Brothers did yeah
and we were inspired by them but also
the four freshmen who had this more
complicated type of style of harmony so
they I think the essential ingredient is
love but you have a deeper voice in just
conversation but you're capable of well
my cousin took the highest part I like
singing the low parts on the ballots but
my lead we wrote the songs together so
it would be in my key
you know it's automatic when I talk with
old friends at conversation turns to
girls we knew the beach was the place we
that was do it again in 1968 we really
redid it with John Stamos in and you
know mark McGrath from Sugar Ray so that
was so fun we did have in July fourth
this year
Stamos getting some mileage here out of
the Beach Boys issues well Stamos had us
on full house and and we get recognized
by kids all over that's great the kids
are now 30 you look great though thank
you you do thank you you look great and
it's great to have you it's it's my
pleasure thank you so much and helping
unleash the love mr. pett unleash the
love Mike love of the Beach Boys his
first solo album in 30 years special
double CD featuring new material as well
as re-recorded Beach play classics maybe
you have guest singers on stage like we
didn't bring you do we do some kind of
time yeah
judge Dave Koz a sex I just invited
myself
what anytime you want damn real out and
do Barbara in with us you you cannot
mess up Barbara okay okay help me out
here go set with Barbara and oh a pop
you're in you're in you're in I think I
went a little too deep though didn't
know that listen we'll rehearse one time
one let's save it for the show okay no
kidding save it for the game Madison
Square Garden Madison Square Garden who
can afford to go there except NBA all
right we'll do a small venue then well
do any we're gonna do something groovy
Oh in this early summer next year and
he's got my name written all over it you
you committed to it I do here Bob Bob
Bob Bob Bob the red thank you Mike thank
you
we'll be back Dan Patrick show right
after this for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]